this is a production of cornell
university
all right here we go um
as i um
have been introduced i'm a wage hour
investigator and have been for
almost 25 years now
um
this presentation um
i will start now is uh going to cover
the legal obligations of agricultural
employers resulting
or relating to the h2a program and
relates to the h2a regulations which
became effective on march 15 2010.
additionally there are three other laws
at wagenauer administers which relate to
agricultural employment and those are
the fair labor standards act the migrant
and seasonal agricultural worker
protection act and field sanitation
standards i won't be covering them but
just know that they exist and you know
they could potentially affect
uh okay so
when there is a shortage of u.s workers
to perform manual farm work the h2a
program allows foreign agricultural
workers to enter the country on a
temporary basis under appropriate
conditions
basically h2a is a non-technical term
based upon the
temporary worker section of the
immigration and nationality act which is
section 101 a15 h2a
the h2a provisions of the ina are
administered by the employment and
training administration and the wage and
hour division of the u.s department of
labor
uh eta is responsible for the
application and certification process
and wage an hour is responsible for the
enforcement of the contra contractual
obligations which apply to the
employment of h2a workers
and workers who are engaged in
corresponding employment
as it says ea is responsible for issuing
or denying labor certifications so
included within that jurisdiction for
eta
are determinations related to such
issues as the availability of u.s
workers positive recruitment
the existence of a striker lockout the
methodology for yourself and i was like
i swear
okay okay belinda keep
keep going we'll turn the sound off on
somebody okay
the adverse effect wage rate which is uh
abbreviated a were for us aewr
the offer of employment to u.s workers
for up to 50 of the contract period and
similar matters
the a were that adverse effect wage rate
is the rate determined by the
administrator of eta that must be
offered and paid at a minimum to every
h2a worker and every domestic worker for
a particular occupation in an area of
intended employment in which an employer
seeks to employ h2a workers
okay
wage our responsibilities which whd
enforces the contractual obligations
related to wages transportation meals
and housing
so
as i said we're responsible for all of
the contractual obligations for h2a
workers and workers in corresponding
employment
corresponding employment applies to the
employment of workers who are not h2a
workers by an employer who has an
approved h2a application and any work
included in the job order or in any
agricultural work performed by h2a
workers
that sounded confusing to me when i read
it
so basically it's any you any worker who
is eligible to work in the united states
um
who does any
occupation listed in the job order or
who is working alongside an h2a worker
maybe not in an occupation listed on the
job order but doing the same work at
that time they would be required to pay
that adverse effect wage rate to
uh any corresponding us worker
okay
oh and to qualify as corresponding
employment the work must be performed
during the validity period of the job
order
and just a note on that as well if for
example your your job order starts on
april 1st
but your
h2a workers are not
in the country until may 1st
the adverse effect wage rate for
corresponding u.s workers is going to go
into effect on april 1st even if the h2a
workers are not in the country yet just
keep that in mind
all right
uh wage an hour is authorized to conduct
inspections
and in appropriate circumstances to
impose penalties collect back wages seek
injunctive relief recommend
excuse me recommend revocation of
existing labor certification and debar
from future program participation
wage an hour also enforces the record
requirements of the regulation
okay so
for the um next slide i'll just read
this off agricultural employers who
anticipate a shortage of u.s workers may
file an application with eta
the application must include a job order
which explains the working conditions
pay and benefits
and then for information related to
eta's responsibility
there's the link there
this presentation focuses primarily on
wage and hours responsibilities and
related employer obligations
okay so definition of agriculture
section three f of the fair labor
standards act
gives the definition
also section three one two one g of the
internal revenue code
it also includes the pressing of apples
for cider on a farm and logging
employment
so work performed within the scope of
either the internal revenue code
of or the flsa definition of agriculture
which includes farming in all its
branches
the raising of livestock bees furbearing
animals poultry forestry or lumbering
operations
logging employment has been included in
the definition of agriculture for h2a as
of
january 17 to 2009
excuse me
logging employment is defined as
operations associated with felling and
moving trees and logs from the stump to
the point of delivery such as but not
limited to
marking danger trees
and trees and logs to be cut to length
felling
limiting
bucking debarking chipping yarding
loading unloading storing and
transporting machines equipment and
personnel to and from
and between logging sites
so that's just kind of telling you what
we consider agriculture
now we go to types of employers there
are three of these
the fixed site employer is going to be
a person who owns or operates a farm
ranch processing establishment cannery
gin packing shed
or other similar fixed site location
where agricultural activities are
performed and who recruits solicits
hires employees houses or transports any
workers subject to the h2a regulation
an agricultural association is any
non-profit or cooperative association of
farmers growers or ranchers incorporated
or qualified under applicable state law
that recruits solicits hires employees
furnishes houses or transports any
worker
an agricultural association may act as
the agent of an employer or as the sole
or joint employer of any worker subject
to the h2a regulations
and
the h2a labor contractor is an employee
employer excuse me that is not a fixed
site employer agricultural association
or an employee of a fixed site employer
or agricultural association and who
recruits solicits hires employees
furnishes houses or transports any
worker subject to the h2a regulations
okay
then we have types of workers
um
correspond
there's h2a and then the non-h2a workers
and corresponding employment
the corresponding employment applies to
the employment of workers who are not
h2a workers by an employer who has an
approved h2a application and any work
included in the job order or any work
performed by h2a workers
the work must be performed during the
validity period of the job order i
basically went over that before just
keep in mind that as soon as the job
order comes into effect that adverse
effect wage rate is applicable
and that's about all i would have to say
about that
corresponding employment
corresponding workers may also be
protected by the migrant and seasonal
worker protection act
so workers in corresponding employment
may be subject to that
but h2a workers are not
migrant and seasonal workers by
definition
they are not
subject to the migrant seasonal worker
protection act
okay employer obligations so this is
what is required
first the job offer must contain the
employer obligations a copy of the job
offer must be given to each
a2h2a worker no later than the time of
visa application and to each
corresponding worker no later than the
first day of employment and you can see
there what the obligations are
disclosure wage requirements the
three-quarter guarantee housing
requirements meals transportation
preferential treatment assurances and
obligations and record-keeping
now we'll talk about disclosure
each copy each worker excuse me must
receive a copy of the work contract or a
copy of the job order if no separate
contract exists
the work contract must include beginning
and ending dates conditions of
employment hours of work rates of pay
and crops
we have always suggested that it's
easiest to just give a copy of the job
order because everything in the job
order must also be
included in the work agreement in order
to satisfy the requirement
so
a written work contract which specifies
the terms and conditions of the
employment agreement between the h2a
employer and a worker may exist
if the written work contract exists and
it provides the same or greater and or
additional labor standards as those in
the job order the work contract will be
enforced by wage an hour it would apply
to both h2a and corresponding workers
if no written work contract
exists the job order and certified
application become the contract which is
enforced
and just
to recap that disclosure must be in a
language the worker understands is
necessary or reasonable
if they speak spanish it should be in
spanish a copy of the work contract must
be provided to h28 workers no later than
the time of visa application a copy of
the work contract must be provided to
corresponding workers no later than the
date work begins
wage requirements
the employer must pay the higher of the
applicable which would be either the
adverse effect wage rate the prevailing
peace rate or hourly wage federal or
state minimum wage
and the agreed-upon collective
bargaining rate
the employer must pay no less often than
semi-monthly and in new york state it is
actually weekly you have no other
option it must be weekly because of new
york state law
only deductions required by law or
disclosed in the contract are permitted
so the prevailing hourly wage rate is
determined as a result of a state agency
prevailing rate survey
the a were
is the rate determined by the
administrator of eta office of foreign
labor certification
that must be offered and paid at a
minimum to every h2a corresponding
worker
pay day must be stated in the job order
and as i said in new york state it must
be weekly
the employer must make deductions
required by law any other deductions
must be disclosed in the job order and
must be reasonable
and basically a reasonable
turns out to be voluntary and cannot
include any profit to the employer
that is that
when the worker is paid by a method
other than an hourly rate the worker
must receive an average
hourly rate that equals or exceeds the
amount stated in the work contract if
not the employer must supplement the
earnings so that the worker averages the
stated hourly rate
and just as an example i can provide to
you
if the adverse effect wage rate is nine
dollars an hour
this is an old example um and piece rate
is 75 cents a basket you have 40 hours
worked in the week total baskets of 500
if you multiply 500 by 75 cents that
equals 375 dollars if you divide 375 by
40 you get 938 you're in compliance
because you are above that nine dollar
rate
okay
the three-quarter guarantee
uh employers must guarantee to offer
employment for at least three quarters
of the total hours promised in the work
contract
guarantee period begins on the first
workday after the worker arrives at the
place of employment so after the
beginning date of the contract
and ends on the date the contract
expires including any extensions
failure to meet this provision require
would require employ the employer to
supplement workers pay to meet the
three-quarter guarantee
so an employer must guarantee
each worker payment for a total
guaranteed number of hours equal to at
least three quarters of the work days
during the contract period
an employee is not required to work more
than the specified daily number of hours
or on federal holidays or the employee's
sabbath the employer may count all hours
actually worked by the employee
and just as an example if your contract
is four weeks there's five days a week
that you're offering in the contract
eight hours a day that's 160 hours
multiply it by three quarters your
guarantee to the worker is that they
will be paid for 120 hours
okay
housing
housing must be provided at no charge to
the employee
inspected before
occupancy and maintained during
occupancy to meet the appropriate osha
or eta standards
so the housing must be provided without
charge to h2a and corresponding workers
who are not reasonably able to return to
the their residence daily
if rental or public housing is provided
charges must be paid directly to the
housing management
the swa the state workforce agency is
responsible for
ensuring that housing is inspected prior
to occupancy housing standards are found
at 29 cfr 1910.142
for osha
and if the housing was constructed
before april 3rd of 1980 you can use the
eta standards which are at 20 cfr 654
so i'm just going to go through the
housing safety and health
requirements
shelter must have protection from the
elements
50 square feet per occupant beds and
storage for each occupant
floors must be smooth and tight there
must be proper ventilation
windows that open
all openings are screened cooking
facilities and compliance with all state
and local codes
here locally that's going to mean that
you're going to have
fire or smoke detectors that's one of
the things that we would be looking for
um
one of the biggest violations we usually
find are that these screened openings
have holes in them
moving on
the site itself must be clear of debris
and uncontrolled weeds on the grounds
there must be adequate drainage and
adequate size to prevent overcrowding
the water supply you have to have safe
drinking water 35 gallons per person
each day
toilet facilities they have to be
adequate for the capacity of the camp
access without passing through sleeping
rooms
provided for each sex if appropriate
well ventilated lighted day and night
and that's if they're separate from
the housing if they're in a separate
building
adequate supply of toilet paper and
maintained in the sanitary condition
laundry hand washing and bathing you
must have one hand washing basin to six
occupants
one shower head to ten one laundry tub
for thirty
one slop sink flowers must be non-slip
with proper drainage must have hot water
and it must be maintained in sanitary
condition
lighting at least one ceiling light
type light per room and one electrical
outlet per room in accordance with state
and local codes
refuse disposal flight tight trash
container that's another area where we
see issues because lids tend to get lost
the garbage container must be kept clean
and emptied at least twice a week
the kitchen and dining hall
maintained according to state and local
codes adequate to the size of the camp
separate from the sleeping corners has
proper refrigeration of food
and then insect and rodent control
prevent infestation by and harborage of
animals or insects vermin or pests
and then first aid you must have
adequate first aid facilities readily
accessible at all times that's another
area where we see you know you might
have a full stock first aid kit at the
beginning of the
contract and when we come in to
conduct a housing inspection they've
been emptied so keep an eye on those
and then sewage disposal facilities
connect to public stores when
available reporting communal
disease to appropriate local health
authorities you must report any
individual with communicable disease and
report any camp outbreak of illness
meals the employer must either provide
meals or provide cooking facilities if
meals are provided to h2a workers they
must also be provided to corresponding
workers on the same basis
i just will note that one of the things
we
have noticed lately is that
the transportation for workers to go to
the store to pick up groceries and such
if there is a an actual employee who's
driving those workers to the store as
opposed to you the employer
um that employer that employee is due
the adverse effect wage rate for those
hours
of driving not the time at the store but
the driving
and then
they must also
have that disclosed in the job order
that there will be driving just so
you're aware
inbound transportation
the employer must provide or pay for
transportation from the place of
recruitment to the work site
the employer may provide in advance for
the most economical means and this can
be recovered from workers wages if this
has been disclosed
at the conclusion of 50 of the contract
period the cost of inbound
transportation and subsistence must be
reimbursed to the worker
flsa obligations apply independently of
the h2a requirements
so
first off the amount for transportation
must be no less than the most economical
and reasonable common carrier
transportation charges for the distance
and it must be from the place of
recruitment
if you have workers that have been
coming back to you for multiple years
the place of recruitment is their home
so you would pay from home to consulate
consulate to a place of employment and
on the reverse the same back to their
their home
if the employer has not advanced or
provided transportation and subsistence
costs to the workers and the worker has
completed 50 percent of the work
contract the employer must pay the
worker for transportation and daily
subsistence from place of recruitment to
place of employment at that time
the daily subsistence changes yearly you
need to check the federal register for
that
and then the part about the flsi
applying independently would be
as an example
if a worker only works
one day in in the week
and
say their pay ended up being
less than
if you add in the transportation costs
if the total amount of pay divided by
the total number of hours they worked
ended up less than the federal minimum
wage is 7.25 then you would have to
bring them up to 725 in order to be
paying them in
compliance with the fair labor standards
act
so just in case that ever comes up
all right
outbound transportation if the worker
completes the contract period the
employer must either provide or pay for
transportation and subsistence from the
living quarters to the place of
recruitment by most economical means or
from current employer to subsequent
employer
absent
agreement from new employer to pay
so
excuse me
you're not obligated to pay
the rich the outbound if they're
if the h2a employee is sent on to
another employer who has agreed to pay
the return transportation
and you are not
obligated to pay the outbound
transportation if the worker quits or is
terminated for cause and the employer
notifies eta
both u.s workers and h2a workers they
have to notify each heta
and dhs
department of homeland security that
only has to be the h2a workers and that
has to be done within two working days
daily transportation the employer must
provide transportation between the
workers living quarters and the work
site at no cost to the workers
transportation safety all employer
provided transportation must comply with
all applicable federal state or local
laws and regulations
at a minimum this transportation must
provide the same vehicle safety
standards driver licensure licensure
and vehicle insurance required under 29
cfr
500.105 and 29 cfr
500.120 through 0.128
okay
some of the other state
laws in new york state that would be
applicable
would be
a seat belt for every passenger
seat a commercial driver's license if
applicable
and
speed limits those are some of the
things that they'd have to obey
referential treatment
the employer's job offered to
corresponding workers must include at
least the same benefits wages and
working conditions provided to h2a
workers
the employer may not impose restrictions
or obligations on workers and
corresponding employment that are not
imposed on the employer's h2a workers
the employer must provide employment to
any qualified eligible u.s worker who
applies until 50 of the work contract
period has elapsed
and just a note on the ins the
restrictions
a lot of times we'll
see that
drug testing is something that is
required in in the job order if you're
only drug testing us workers and not h2a
workers
wage an hour would consider that
preferential treatment
okay
assurances and obligations
the employer must assure that there have
been no layoffs of similarly employed
u.s workers within 60 days of the date
of need except for lawful job related
reasons
and if such a lot layoff has occurred
the employer must first offer the job
opportunity to those laid off u.s
workers before hiring any h2a workers
a layoff is only permissible if all h2a
workers are laid off before
corresponding workers
and if the worker is not able willing or
qualified for the job opportunity the
employer may refuse to hire the worker
but must document that in the
recruitment report
tools equipments and supplies required
to perform the assigned duties must be
provided at no charge
state workers compensation insurance or
its equivalent must be provided at no
cost
if completion of the contract is
impossible due to an act of god the
employer may request that eta approve
cancellation of the job order
a determination is made by the eta
certifying officer
the employer must try to transfer the
worker to comparable employment
acceptable to the worker consistent with
the ina
and if a transfer is not possible the
employer must return the worker at no
cost to the place from which the worker
came
so
if
services are not required for reasons
beyond the control of the employer due
to fire weather or other active god that
makes fulfillment of the contract and
plot impossible
the employer may terminate the work
contract again determined by the eta
certifying officer you can't make the
decision yourself you have to go to eta
and get that determination
in the event of such a termination the
employer shall fulfill the three-quarter
guarantee for the time that has elapsed
from the start of the contract
to the termination due to the act of god
and if their workers are not transferred
they must be returned to the place from
which they came
and then finally employers and their
agents are prohibited from seeking or
receiving payments from workers related
to obtaining labor certification
so government mandated fees such as visa
application border crossing and visa
fees are integral to the employer's
choice to use the h2a program and are
fees that must be borne by the employer
recruitment of the four
foreign workers is an expense to be
borne by the employer
passport fee like obtaining a passport
would be an expense that would be borne
by the worker
and then employers must comply with all
other applicable federal state and local
laws and regulations including the
prohibition against holding workers
passports or other immigration documents
employers must
display a poster at the job site which
details the rights and protections for
workers in a conspicuous location and in
a language common to a significant
portion of the workers we have them
available in both spanish and english
you can order them over the internet or
you can call our office in buffalo and
we can get one for you
or mail one out to you
and then
the h2a labor contractor has certain
another
obligation added onto them which would
be a surety bond
every application requires one and the
amount is dependent on the number of
employees listed in the application
the bond must be written to cover
liability incurred during the time of
the job and must remain in force no less
than two years from the expiration of
the order again that's only for the h2a
labor contractor
record keeping
the following earnings information must
be maintained field tally records number
of hours offered and worked
the beginning and ending times of work
each day
the rate of pay
earnings per pay period
home address and deductions
records must be maintained for three
years
and deductions must be explained in
writing if the hours worked are less
than offered the records must show the
reason for example you have
eight hours of work available on a
monday and the worker says i'm too sick
to come
you document
eight hours offered
employee's sick
the employer must provide each worker
with a written earnings statement no
later than each payday the earning
statement must include all required
payroll information
one of the things that we do notice uh
missing on that pay stub is your federal
employer identification number that must
be on the pay stub
and if you do pay pipe by piece rate you
must include both hours worked and
pieces earned
so compliance assistance materials
would be the immigration and nationality
act the regulations of 20 cfr part 655
subpart b
and 29 cfr part 501
fact sheet number 26
section h2a of the immigration and
nationality act
workers rights card and the poster
and then information on the application
process any office of the u.s department
of labor employment and training
administration can assist interested
parties in the h2a application process
eta will specify who may apply where to
apply and how to apply
and then you can see the website there
any of the office of the us department
of labor wage and our division can
provide compliance assistance with the
h2a worker protection requirements and
there is our website you can also call
our office
we are more than willing to
provide compliance assistance this will
not trigger an investigation i promise
i just we much prefer to provide the
information ahead of time than have to
come in on the back end
and then you can contact us at the wagen
hour division home page
www.dol.gov
that's whd
we have the toll-free information and
helpline which is one eight six six four
u s wage
or you can call our ver visit the
nearest wage in our division office our
office number is 716-842-3240
and that's our general disclaimer um
informational only does not carry the
force of legal opinion
and that is it
thank you belinda i'll open this up for
questions you can either ask since we
have a small group you could unmute and
you could ask belinda directly or you
could put something into the chat
i have a question regarding
um i guess would be receipts for
reimbursement for things like inbound
travel
is there a
a set amount
how are we determining what that cost of
transportation is from the
employees
home
to the embassy and then
um
cost of hotels and things like that do
they need to provide receipts
things like that
they don't re
the receipt is not required but if they
do provide a receipt then obviously you
would pay what they've incurred
if they don't provide a receipt then
what you can do is look at
the most economical means of
transportation to get from say their
home to
the consulate generally that's going to
be a bus
um you know if they choose to take
a a flight
instead of a bus you're still only
obligated to pay that bus fare
um
the hotel and
subsistence in
in
usually monterey
most of the time i've i've seen that
workers do tend to keep the receipts for
those maybe not for food but for for
hotel for sure and then for for
subsistence you could just go with the
the daily rate that's in the federal
register
i don't is that helpful
it it is it's um
i mean when i
i do the same thing when i
when the employees return is that i will
look up
say the cost of a bus to return them to
their home and then the cost of a plane
um
and even if the cost of a bus is
is cheaper they prefer to go on the
plane
so i just kind of um
allow the subsistence from the cost of
the difference in the cost of the bus
and the plane
um and allow that for subsistence
but i'm
particularly talking about when they are
going from their home when they get
called to to come to the embassy how to
figure out what
i should be paying them for that
transportation
and now you say um
going on say
greyhound and you know a greyhound site
or something like that and looking up
the the price
that they would pay
yeah that's generally what i have done
in the past when an employer hasn't done
it is i will just uh
google
transportation from say veracruz to
monterey
um
and look and see what the
the most economical price is it might
not be the best way to get there it
might take two days it might be
something they would never choose but
it's
the
regulation only requires that you pay
the most economical way to to get there
so
they're not providing you with a receipt
saying you know this is what the cost
was that i incurred
and again even if they do um
say they decide to take a flight from
bear crews to monterey you are only
required to pay that minimum
you know the most economical way of
doing it so you could still look it up
and
pay that uh
rate just as long as you document
everything that's all i would say is if
you if you go on
google and you
find the bus
uh
cost
just print out that page so if you have
a wage now our investor irrigator come
to see you say this is what i did here's
the
information and we'll look at it and say
yep okay great thank you
okay all right um yeah i mean i was just
worried about
um whether i have to take them work
their word for it i have also had also
heard that there was a
an average amount that was being paid so
all right i just want i wasn't right
definitely not the average amount it's
going to
change for every worker it's going to
change depending on
where they're coming from so definitely
not an average amount um as far as again
taking their word for it
if if they say they you know if if they
give you an amount and you think it's
ridiculously overpriced you can look up
what the most economical method is and
document it and
provide that as the
the reimbursement
okay thank you
yep
um linda i had a message that came up in
the chat just to me and they want to
know if it's possible to go over the
adverse effect wage rate again please
okay um
i'm not exactly sure where you want to
go over it if it's and how it's
determined
i don't have anything to do with that
basically um it would be it's determined
by based on surveys
and uh you would
get notification
um
through the federal register again what
the the adverse effect wage rate is
so
if it's as far as enforcing it
um i can tell you that
the
rate the adverse effect wage rate would
be in effect from the date the contract
goes into effect
until the date the contract is no longer
in effect
and
maybe the question might be
with u.s workers who are doing that same
work
and i kind of gave that example if if
the contract goes into effect on april
1st but your h2a workers don't show up
till may 1st
all your u.s workers who are doing work
in that job order are required to be
paid the adverse effect wage rate
starting april 1st
um
as far as
any other questions that might come up
about it
that we've seen um a lot of times
a job order will only be for say working
in the fields cultivating
weeding picking that kind of thing but
there is a time towards the end of the
season where
the employer is
short of workers in the packing house
and decides to bring workers in from the
field h2a workers and from the field
that's not in the job order
but
once an h2a worker comes in and starts
doing that work
everyone who's doing that work is
subject to the adverse effect wage rate
so everyone working with that h2a worker
would be
paid
the adverse effect wage rate while
they're working with an h2a worker
and there might be times
where
something isn't listed in the job order
but it is a regular duty and i
mentioned driving as being one of them
um
if it's something that the h2a worker is
doing
they're required to get the adverse
effect wage rate for anything that they
do
um
i don't know if that answers your the
question but
if they have something more specific i
would be more than happy to try and go
there
dave do you want to on unmute and ask
your question he did write back sayings
specifically paying for h2a drivers the
aewr versus hourly rate
yep that that would definitely be um
something that we've seen lately
um
any time that
an h2a worker is going to be
driving other employees h2a workers
either one corresponding u.s workers h2a
workers whatever if they're driving them
as a condition of their employment that
you know it's required by the employer
that they do this
um
and that includes going to the store
because the employer must provide means
for them to get to the to the market
um to purchase
food
um that
employee is required to pay be paid the
adverse effect wage rate for that time
now if it's a
not in the job order
and you have a regular u.s employee who
is driving your h2a workers to the store
they can get their hourly rate
i have another question related to
the minimum
wage or the hourly wage
um relating to piece work
when you gave the example before
um if a worker was doing piece work
uh that obviously they have to make it
and make at least the minimum wage on
the job order
does that
apply to each individual crop and i'll
try to explain what i'm talking about
we have several crops where we have
peace rates listed in our job order
that are different because the either
the box sizes are different or
the type of crop it is
at the end of the week when you are
[Music]
determining whether or not for a
particular crop they have met
the minimum
needed meaning the the minimum wage for
the contract
is that determined per crop or is it
determined overall
i don't know
i understand it yep um if it is
or at the end of the week it is actually
based on the total
amount paid overall it's not per crop so
you would
determine how much the worker earned
divided by the total hours as long as
the total per hour
is above the adverse effect wage rate
or the piece rate if it's higher um
then you're in compliance
okay
thank you
yep
okay one more question related to the
piecework
and um
on our earnings statement
uh or their their pay statement
um
does
we have several crops that are listed at
the
the same
piece rate uh
for instance radishes cilantro and dill
they are all
listed as or they are they all receive
the same they have all have the same
piecework rate
um
can they be combined or do they have to
be listed separately that they picked
this many cilantro this many radishes
this much dill
do each of those items need to be listed
separate or can they be grouped together
as
let's just say uh the piece rate is
dollar fifty they pick so many boxes at
a dollar fifty
they you can do it as one group of
if it was fifty fifty and fifty they
they picked 150 at a dollar fifty you
could combine that as 150 pieces at a
dollar fifty yes
okay
other questions take advantage of
belinda while we have her here
okay seeing as there aren't any more
questions um
nothing's coming over chat i suppose we
can
we can log out belinda i do want to
thank you for a wonderful presentation i
don't understand so much of this being a
production person but thank you so much
for joining us today
you're welcome i was happy to do so okay
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu